twelve years ago I picked up a camera
for the first time to film the olive
harvest in a Palestinian village in the
West Bank I thought I was there to make
a single documentary and we then move on
to some other part of the world but
something kept bringing me back now
usually when international audiences
hear about that part of the world they
often just want that conflict to go away
the israeli-palestinian conflict is bad
and we wish it could just disappear we
feel much the same way about other
conflicts around the world but every
time we turn our attention to the news
it seems like one more country has gone
up in flames
so I've been wondering whether we should
not start looking at conflict in a
different way with instead of simply
wishing to end conflict with focus
instead on how to wage conflict this has
been a big question for me when I've
pursued together with my team as a
nonprofit just vision after witnessing
several different kinds of struggles in
the Middle East I started noticing some
patterns on the more successful ones I
wondered where do these variables held
across cases and if they did what
lessons we could glean for waging
constructive conflict in Palestine
Israel and elsewhere there is some
science about this in a study of three
hundred and twenty three major political
conflicts from 1900 to 2006
Maria Stephan and Erica Chenoweth found
that nonviolent campaigns were almost
100 percent more likely to lead to
success than violent campaigns
nonviolent campaigns are also less
likely to cause physical harm to those
waging the campaign as well as their
opponents and critically they typically
lead to more peaceful and democratic
society
in other words nonviolent resistance is
a more effective and constructive way of
waging conflict but if that's such an
easy choice why don't more groups use it
political scientists Victor asal and
colleagues have looked at several
factors that shape a political groups
choice of tactics and it turns out that
the greatest predictor of a movements
decision to adopt non-violence or
violence is not whether that group is
more left-wing or right-wing not whether
the group is more or less influenced by
religious beliefs now whether it's up
against a democracy or a dictatorship
and not even the levels of repression
that that group is facing the greatest
predictor of a movements decision to
adopt non-violence is its ideology
regarding the role of women in public
life when a movement includes in its
discourse language around gender
equality it increases dramatically the
chances it will adopt non-violence and
does the likelihood it will succeed the
research squared up with my own
documentation of political organizing in
Israel and Palestine I've noticed that
movements which welcomed women into
leadership positions such as the one I
documented in a village called Buddhist
were much more likely to achieve their
goals this village was under a real
threat of being wiped off the map when
Israel started building the separation
barrier the proposed route would require
the destruction of this community's
olive groves their cemeteries and would
ultimately enclose the village from all
sides through inspired local leadership
they launched a non-violent resistance
campaign to stop that from happening
the odds were massively stacked against
them but they had a secret weapon a 15
year old girl who courageously jumped in
front of a bulldozer which was about to
approve an olive tree
topping it in that moment the community
of Buddha's realized what was possible
if they welcomed and encouraged women to
participate in public life and so it was
that the women of Buddha's went to the
frontlines day after day using their
creativity and acumen to overcome
multiple obstacles they faced in a
10-month unarmed struggle and as you can
probably tell at this point they win at
the end the separation barrier was
changed completely to the
internationally recognized green line
and the women of Buddhist came to be
known across the West Bank for the
indomitable energy when a pause for a
second which you helped me do because I
do want to tackle two very serious
misunderstandings that could happen at
this point
the first one is that I don't believe
women are inherently or essentially more
peaceful than men but I do believe that
in today's world women experience power
differently having had to navigate being
in the less powerful position in
multiple aspects of their life women are
often more adept at how to serve
piteously pressure for change against
large powerful actors the term
manipulatives often charge against women
in a derogatory way reflects the reality
in which women have often had to find
ways other than direct confrontation to
achieve their goals and finding
alternatives to direct confrontation is
at the core of nonviolent resistance
now the second potential
misunderstanding I've been talking a lot
about make Spears in the Middle East and
some of you might be thinking now that
the solution then is for us to educate
Muslim and Arab societies to be more
inclusive of their women if we were to
do that they will be more successful
they do not need this kind of help
women have been part of the most
influential movements coming out of the
Middle East but they tend to be
invisible for the international
community
our cameras are largely focused on the
man who often end up involved in the
more confrontational things that we find
so irresistible in our new cycle and we
end up with a narrative then not only
you raises women from the struggles in
the region but often misrepresents the
struggles themselves in the late 1980s
an uprising started in Gaza and quickly
spread to the West Bank and East
Jerusalem it came to be known as the
First Intifada and people have any
visual memory of it
generally conjure up something like this
Palestinian man throwing rocks at
Israeli tanks the news coverage at a
time made it seem like stones Molotov
cocktails and burning tires were the
only activities taking place in day to
fada
this period Oh was also marked by
widespread nonviolent organizing in the
forms of strikes sit-ins and the
creation of parallel institutions during
the First Intifada host sectors of the
Palestinian civilian population
mobilized
cutting across generations factions and
class lines they did this through
networks of popular committees and their
use of direct action and communal
self-help project challenged Israel's
very ability to continue ruling the West
Bank and Gaza according to the Israeli
army itself 97 percent of activities
during the First Intifada were unarmed
and here's another thing that is not
part of our narrative about that time
for 18 months sending to father women
were the ones calling the shots behind
the scenes Palestinian women from all
walks of life in charge of mobilizing
hundreds of thousands of people in a
concerted effort to withdraw consent
from the occupation
Nayla Yash who strive to build a
self-sufficient Palestinian economy by
encouraging women in Gaza
to grow vegetables in their backyard an
activity deemed illegal by the Israeli
authorities at a time
Rebecca Diab who took over
decision-making authority for the entire
uprising when the man who had been
running it were deported
Fatima Jaffrey who swallowed leaflets
containing the prizes directives in
order to spread them across the
territories without getting hot and
Zahira Kemal who ensured the longevity
of the uprising by leading an
organization that went from 25 women to
3,000 in a single year despite the
extraordinary achievements none of these
women have made it into our narrative of
the First Intifada we do this in other
parts of the globe - in our history
books for instance and in our collective
consciousness men are the public faces
and spokespersons for the 90/60 struggle
for racial justice in the United States
but women were also a critical driving
force mobilizing organizing taking to
the streets
how many of us think of septima Clark
when we think of the United States civil
rights era
remarkably few but she played a crucial
role in every phase of the struggle
particularly by emphasizing literacy and
education
she's been omitted ignored like so many
other women who played critical roles in
the United States civil rights movement
this is not about getting credit it's
more profound than that the stories we
tell matter deeply to how we see
ourselves and to how we believe
movements are run and how movements are
won the stories we tell about a movement
like the First Intifada or United States
civil rights era
deeply and have a critical influence in
the choices Palestinians Americans and
people around the world will make next
time they encounter an injustice and
develop the courage to confront it if we
do not lift up the women who played
critical roles in these struggles we
fail to offer up role models to future
generations without role models it
becomes harder for women to take up
their rightful space in public life and
as we saw earlier one of the most
critical variables in determining
whether a movement will be successful or
not is the movements ideology regarding
the role of women in public life this is
the question of whether we're moving
towards more democratic and peaceful
societies in a world where so much
change is happening and we're changes
bound to continue at an increasingly
faster pace it is not a question of
whether we will face conflict but rather
question of which stories will shape how
we choose to wait conflict thank you